comment faire que les humains dans très
longtemps comprennent que la à cet
endroit précisément il ya un danger
depuis l'egypte antique les chats sont
toujours associés aux humains les
humains qui fléchit et donc ils ont fait
un chat qui lorsqu'ils s'approchent d'un
déchet radioactif devient violet et sont
dit si les humains dans 500 ans on voit
ça ils vont se dire il ya un truc des
clochards bas dans cette forêt il ya
quelque chose qui se passe
donc là on veut juste pas abîmer les
capteurs qui sont à l'entrée de cette
première galerie
c'est pour ça qu'on ralenti tout
simplement
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue que vous avez
pu le voir dans les images juste avant
je me suis retrouvé à quelques temps à
500 mètres sous terre
alors j'ai eu la chance de visiter cigéo
c'est le centre industriel de stockage
géologique est donc cette vidéo est
réalisée en partenariat avec l'andra
l'agencé nationale pour la gestion des
déchets radioactifs
alors on se calme ce n'est pas une vidéo
publicitaire je vais pas essayer de nous
vendre à la technologie nucléaire et
vous affirmer que c'est la solution à
tous nos problèmes mais je vais essayer
de vous expliquer pourquoi
quand on est archéologue la question des
déchets nucléaires peut être
passionnante
pourquoi une émission sur une chaîne
d'archéologie parlerait de déchets
nucléaires
que viennent faire des sciences humaines
et sociales dans un domaine
habituellement chasse gardée des
physiciens à la réponse m'a pas paru
évidente au départ et j'avoue que mes
connaissances sur le sujet était plus
qu'approximative on connaît un peu en
archéologie la radioactivité puisque le
carbone radioactifs le carbone 14 nous
permet de faire des datations on connaît
surtout très bien les déchets éclats de
silex pots cassés et autres poubelles
antique mais l'association des deux
était quelque chose pour moi d'assez
nouveau les déchets radioactifs sont de
plusieurs natures
alors ça peut être des déchets issus de
la médecine de la recherche de la
défense ou de l'industrie dans
l'électronucléaire
mais ceux qui font le plus parler d'eux
sont bien sûr les résidus des
combustibles des centrales nucléaires
ces déchets là peuvent être hautement
radioactifs c'est à dire que le
rayonnement qu'il produise peut être
très dangereux pour les organismes
vivants je vous renvoie vers une vidéo
de l'andra qui explique sa très
clairement puisque ce n'est pas le sujet
dont je vais parler ici l'andra et donc
l'organisme public en france qui gère
ces déchets depuis 1979 elle les stocks
dans des centres le temps que leur
radioactivité diminue et charge des
solutions pour que leur impact soit le
plus minime possible sur nous et les
générations futures car le fond du
problème est là les déchets nucléaires
ont une durée de vie gigantesque
certains resteront de siph plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'années
la question qui se pose à l'andra et à
tous ceux qui réfléchissent à la gestion
des déchets nucléaires n'est pas qu'une
question technologique
même si cela demande des années d'études
de terrain comme avec 6 géo sceller une
caisse de béton ou un cylindre d'acier à
500 mètres de profondeur n'a rien de
scientifiquement impossible mais comme
ce n'est pas mon domaine de spécialité
je vais laisser ces considérations
techniques à d'autres l'autre mission de
l'andra celle qui nous intéresse est
aussi de faire comprendre aux citoyens
la nécessité de ce travail de gestion et
de faire en sorte que l'on garde la
mémoire de ces sites de stockage pendant
au moins cinq siècles durée pendant
laquelle il faut absolument éviter toute
intrusion qui exploserait dangereusement
les personnes deux scénarios sont
possibles
1 la mémoire du site se conserve bien
deux la mémoire du site se perdre ou se
dégrade dans le premier cas aucun
problème
les déchets seront conservés sous terre
dans le deuxième cas en revanche il
existe un risque
le site peut être oublié pour toujours
au quelqu'un à c'est tant mieux mais il
peut aussi être redécouverts si c'est le
cas et que découvrir le fouille sans que
sa dangerosité soit bien comprise il
risque une exposition mortelle
moralité il n'y a que le scénario un qui
marche à tous les coups
l'oubli voilà l'enjeu qui nous intéresse
comment faire pour ne pas oublier
l'oubli touche tout et tout le monde et
il n'y a rien de plus imprévisible que
la mémoire ni l'un ni l'autre ne peuvent
se décréter pourquoi a t'on retenu la
date de la bataille de marignan et pas
celle de pavie pourquoi prend ton
aujourd'hui que l' empire romain s'est
effondré en 476 alors que personne à
l'époque ni a fait attention ce sont les
chemins tortueux de la mémoire et du
sens que nous donnons aujourd'hui à
toutes ces choses la mémoire est donc un
sujet d'histoire qui nous amène en toute
logique à réexaminer le passé mais
toujours en lien avec le présent en ce
qui concerne les déchets nucléaires la
mémoire ne raisonne pas au passé mais au
futur comment évolueront nos sociétés
dans les siècles à venir
que penseront nos successeurs de cette
pratique de stockage pour une fois c'est
dans la projection que nous devons
envisager la mémoire celle des
générations futures
et comment faire pour garder la mémoire
aussi longtemps nos anciens avaient
trouvé une technique imparable pour
garder leurs données
gravé dans le marbre ainsi des siècles
et des siècles plus tard la forma hors
bis nous livre de façon fragmentaire une
carte antique de rome
si efficace et jolie soit il ce procédé
n'est plus viable
à l'heure des big data bien faut
sérieusement repensée l'orientation
professionnelle de nos jeunes
lewin as en matière de sauvegarde de
données sont dernièrement des chercheurs
de southampton ayant mis au point le
procédé sobrement intitulé superman
memri christophe un disque de cristal
capable de garder 13
milliards d'années les chefs-d'oeuvre de
l'humanité à ce jour en ont bénéficié
la bible le traité d'optique de newton
et la déclaration universelle des droits
de l'homme
il faudra attendre un peu avant de
pouvoir sauvegarder nos salles fille
tous pourris néanmoins à l'andra a aussi
recours à la gravure sur disque de
saphir pour situer l'emplacement des
sites de stockage de déchets et en
détailler le contenu à 25000 euros le
support l' agence dispose de trois
disques dont la durée de vie est tout de
même d'un million d'années une autre
piste étudiée par l'andra et celle du
son langage universel laissant une forte
empreinte sur la mémoire de celui ou
celle qui l'écoutent et donc plus à même
de traverser les époques les sons ont la
particularité de véhicules et du sens
des émotions et de se retenir facilement
ne reste plus qu'à trouver un sont
capables de transmettre la mise en garde
à travers les âges
[Musique]
l'andra s'inspire aussi d'un principe
plusieurs fois millénaire pour ne pas
oublier
il faut des marqueurs dans le paysage
certains monuments ont réussi eux à ne
jamais être oublié pensez aux pyramides
de gizeh des tas de pierres 240 mètres
de haut qui trône depuis 5000 ans aux
yeux de tous le meilleur coup de com de
l'histoire mais quand on y pense et
pyramides sont presque les seules
constructions à avoir défié l'oubli
temps plus grandiose au mexique au
cambodge en grèce ou en italie temps de
construction faite pour durer toujours
et qui ont sombré sous la végétation où
les constructions postérieur la majorité
des objets archéologiques sont oubliées
enfouis puis redécouvert justement ce
qu'on cherche à éviter dans notre cas
plutôt que d'ériger des pyramides au
dessus des déchets nucléaires
deux artistes stéphane perreault est
haram kebab dian ont proposé à l'andra
en 2015 de matérialiser un site de
stockage par une forêt bleue cette zone
bleue nom donné à l'oeuvre serait en
réalité un site touristique qui
informerait les passants de la
dangerosité potentielle du lieu par sa
couleur originale le bleu choisi en
référence aux bleus tcherenkov visible
dans les réacteurs nucléaires lors d'un
phénomène de propagation des ondes
traduit la nature des déchets dans le
sol pour faire mémoire le choix est ici
celui de la vulgarisation de
l'exposition au grand public et non de
son camouflage mais cela ne suffit pas
au delà des solutions matérielles
graves est sonnée construire il faut
aussi investiguer le processus mental et
social de la mémoire
qu'est ce qui fait qu'une société se
souvient ou non d'un lieu où d'un
événement qu'est ce qui fait qu'on
décide de ne pas oublier pour imaginer
cela dans le futur on peut bien sûr
s'inspirer des exemples du passé
les exemples du passé nous montre qu'il
est extrêmement difficile de défier
l'oubli prenons le cas des épisodes de
catastrophes naturelles qui cause des
morts et des destructions même des
événements aussi marquants et tragiques
peuvent être aisément oublier au japon
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle on érige
est ainsi des bandes de pierres placées
dans les champs à l'endroit où la vague
d'un tsunami s'était arrêté pour en
garder la mémoire dessus était grave et
des indications telles que la date et un
conseil adressé à ceux qui la lierait ne
construisez pas vos maisons en dessous
de cette limite parfois respecter
souvent oublié ce conseil n'aura pas
permis d'éviter les milliers de victimes
lors de l'effroyable tsunami de 2011
autre exemple les éruptions volcaniques
en italie à proximité immédiate du
vésuve il encore des centaines de
milliers de personnes
pourtant personne n'ignore que le volcan
est actif et qu'il a déjà rayé de la
carte des villes entières comme pompéi
herculanum très bien décrite par les
auteurs antiques
cette éruption est toujours dans la
mémoire collective deux mille ans plus
tard si le volcan se réveiller il y
aurait de très nombreuses victimes
dernier exemple l'effondrement d'une
montagne dans le massif de la chartreuse
en savoie le mot granier s'est en partie
effondré et a enseveli 5 villages en
landes ou 148 causant la mort de
centaines de personnes
la montagne présente toujours une
falaise instable et libère régulièrement
des roches qui s'écrase en contrebas
cette zone reste toujours
inconstructibles et interdite aux
promeneurs
la menace est évidente imposante comme
le vésuve
mais cette fois ci n'a pas été ignoré si
la mémoire du danger et plus ou moins
pris en compte dans ces trois exemples
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes
contraintes sur les sociétés il est en
effet très facile de ne plus construire
sous le mont granier en savoie cela ne
concerne que quelques hectares et ne
dérangent pas grand monde
en revanche imaginer ne plus construire
au bord de la mer sur tout l'archipel du
japon où évacuer définitivement toute la
baie de naples est purement et
simplement inimaginable
quand la contrainte est trop forte quel
que soit le danger l'avertissement
risque bien d'être sciemment oublié
on sait que le vésuve est dangereux mais
il vaut mieux l'oublier se dire que ça
n'arrivera pas ou qu'on aura le temps de
s'enfuir en cas d'éruption même une
mémoire bien entretenues ne garantit pas
que le problème sera pris en compte
on l'a dit en début de vidéo à première
vue l'association archéologie nucléaire
n'était pas évidente
à présent il apparaît clairement que les
considérations sociales et culturelles
occupent une large place dans le
traitement de nos déchets nucléaires le
sujet de la mémoire est un exemple
parfait de ce que peuvent apporter les
sciences humaines et sociales à des
domaines techniques
il prouve que les progrès technologiques
ne solutionne pas tout les compétences
techniques ne garantissent pas leur
réception par les sociétés c'est pour
cette raison que delà d'une intelligence
technologique les chercheurs s'emploient
à développer une intelligence sociale
des techniques
la technique se heurte à la société et
inversement peu importe le risque est le
symbole mobilisés si une société n'a pas
envie de gérer un problème elle ne le
fera pas l'ethnologie recense d'ailleurs
plusieurs cas de sociétés qui bloque les
avancées technologiques pour être moins
contrainte socialement en amérique du
sud ou en papouasie par exemple souvent
ce rejet il ya une volonté de ne pas
transformer le rapport à la nature du
moins la représentation que l'on s'en
fait cosmogonies mythologie et onirisme
salines
godelier des scola dont j'ai déjà
présenté les travaux dans mes vidéos ont
mis en évidence ces systèmes de blocage
les papous en adoptant la hache
métalliques non pas pour autant
intensifier leur productivité agricole
ce temps gagné par l'abandon des outils
de pierre a été immédiatement utilisé
pour faire la guerre ou organiser des
cérémonies rituelles part pour cultiver
plus en amérique du sud cette fois
plusieurs populations refusent de
domestiquer des espèces animales
c'est le cas du pécari petits cochons
qui se prête parfaitement à l'élevage
pour connaît la technique on de
simplement pas l'appliquer on a eu par
contre aucun mal à domestiquer il ya
deux mille ans le canard de barbarie ou
le chien les choix faits par ces
populations sont d'ordre social
la technologie qu une technique qu'elles
soient agricoles spatiale ou nucléaire
c'est en fait une relation entre
l'humain et l'outil pour qu'elle soit
retenue jamais oublier il faut que
certaines conditions sociales soient
réunies cette idée est bien admise chez
les archéologues ethnologues mais
visiblement peu vulgariser auprès du
grand public et des chercheurs des
autres disciplines scientifiques
les techniques paradoxalement ne sont
pas des choses du guide escola mais
plutôt des processus d'identification
d'objectivation qui permettent de mettre
un peu de soi l'intérieur
si l'objet est impénétrable non
identifiable ne renvoie à rien de ce qu
un individu expérimentaux cours de sa
vie alors aucune attention nice rapporté
il serait donc bien naïf de penser que
la menace représentée par les déchets
nucléaires obligerait nos descendants à
s'en préoccuper
car qui nous dit que le nucléaire et ses
déchets ne seront pas tabou dans
quelques siècles qui nous dit que
d'autres événements importants parfois
tragiques n'occuperont pas les sociétés
futures guerres et épidémies révolte et
crise climatique
occultant ses fameux colis souterrain
impossible de prévoir
peut-être qu une mythologie du nucléaire
et à imaginer après tout achille jésus
et bouddha sont toujours parler d'eux
qu'elles soient orale ou écrite la
transmission s'est faite on pourrait
peut-être aussi supposer que pour qu'une
société s'occupe d'un problème il
faudrait que les individus qui la
composent vivent dans de bonnes
conditions
c'est une large partie de la population
connaît la précarité des conditions
climatiques de plus en plus extrêmes et
donc d'autres préoccupations il est peu
probable qu'elles s'identifient aux
problèmes de déchets invisible légué par
les ancêtres
alors que faire il faut et c'est ce que
fait déjà l'andra associer les sciences
humaines et sociales à la réflexion
tirer profit des quantité d'exemples et
de connaissances accumulées par les
anthropologues utilisé pour une fois ces
disciplines dont on nous répète souvent
qu'elles ne servent à rien sous prétexte
qu'elles n'ont pas d'applications
techniques travaillent incertain et de
longue haleine cette collaboration reste
bien plus réaliste que de miser sur un
hypothétique oublie définitif toutes les
solutions imaginées jusqu'à présent pour
faire perdurer la mémoire se heurte à
l'échelle du temps on ne peut
aujourd'hui que concevoir des solutions
assez durables pour laisser le temps aux
générations futures de trouver leurs
propres moyens de transmettre la mémoire
et surtout pour s'assurer qu'elle
n'oublie pas de le faire
moralité partager cette vidéo une fois
par mois à tout votre entourage et
demandez à vos enfants de faire pareil
après votre mort ça me semble être la
seule solution pour s'en souvenir
tous
le ton mais faire un autre temps c'est
vrai ça fait un an qu'on est dessus et
il ya que ça faut vraiment faire se
partagent ce mot va tous crever
[Musique]